hey guys welcome back to the Spates
water lad podcast dance and France
preview show and here we are forget
about the uneven draw because what it
has given us this week is the best ever
quarterfinal matchups and I mean ever I
reckon this is some of the best games
you will ever see in a Rugby World Cup
quarterfinals four games basically where
you could flipper coins super even games
which sets us up for an incredible
weekend of code really looking for for
to getting into this one but before we
get into the preview we must look back
at last week cuz what a week last week
was some huge games um this Rugby World
Cup just keeps on giving we saw Portugal
get up and some unbelievable moments in
last week's round so as always we do
have two of the great new zealanders
they're both hitting the airwaves on New
Zealand radio at the moment with snz
which is awesome to see it's suly from
sirly talk Sport and Jake the Snake
Atkins how are we heads you guys good
snaky mate you're a honoring New
Zealander now how good is that mate the
pods going so well the feedbacks flowing
in and US kiwis bro we claim people real
quick when things are going well so yeah
welcome to New Zealand oh boys I'm more
than happy to be a kiwi this week as
well lad I don't know if you boys are
aware but the real world cup started in
India seven days ago
and our national pride and joy the jewel
in our sporting Crown our England's
men's white bull cricket team got an
absolute High in from the black cap so
I'm switching allegiances get me that
passport boys get me away from this
country well we've got a good game to
start with with our review um obviously
New Zealand versus
Uruguay um pretty much win as predicted
we obviously couldn't top the 96 points
we put on Italy but still a very
impressive performance from the all
black lads what did you make of that one
sirle yeah I thought you were a guy for
the first 20 minutes were were really
good like obviously they held us to nil
all there but it was more the the way in
which they did it like they were up for
it they're a physical team uh they
bought some good line speed plenty of
passion plenty of heart at rck time as
well and it was kind of from that stage
on though where they started to fall off
those one-off tackles and that's when
the All Blacks really got into their
work I think once we're allowed to get
into our Rhythm it was probably a
frustrating first 20 minutes for the
boys but once we got a roll on we kind
of flexed our muscles and again we saw
like our ability to play off quick ball
to improvise to score some amazing tries
like will Jordan Leicester it was Fins
Up all day long across my TV screens I'm
sure Jimmy you were fizzing at home as a
North Harbor fan it really started to
piss me off but when it's in your
national colors you got to celebrate
these tries so I was finding myself on
the couch ripping a couple Fins Up
myself but yeah some some great tries
being scored it was fun rugby to watch
that Damen McKenzie slap back whatever
you want to call it a pass I don't know
like the guy's a freak he's the only guy
that could pull something like that off
but he did it so casually and so easily
like they looked at the replays thinking
he was out just cuz it looked like he
just didn't care it took zero effort
from him but yeah it was a fun game to
watch was it the best test leading into
quarterfinals I'm sure we'll find out
but another chance to get some KS into
the legs and just yeah build on what
we've seen from that Italy performance
Daman McKenzie he is an absolute was it
man he played well and I'm good to see
him on the bench for this game coming
for cuz he's a sort of spark plug you
you want coming off that bench whether
you're chasing or you're in front he's
just got things happen around him and
he's probably been one of the form
players of the pool play so far so
awesome to see him get rewarded but you
mentioned the fins up and I did see that
was one of the top things searched on
Google after that game was all blacks
try celebration what is this all black
try celebration so good news for all you
Tasman fans we are trending in World
rugby so fin Christy was doing it when
they weren't even doing it behind them
what a best day that bers jez he was
making sure no one forgot about it cuz
um if you do forget you do get in a bit
of trouble from the Tasman lads who will
be blowing up if you're scoring on the
big stage and not putting your f up so
I'm good to see so many and hopefully we
see a few more this weekend but the next
game was France V Italy I think this
game was pretty similar to what we
predicted as well we thought France
wouldn't be able to get to the 96 either
but they still it was still a pretty
convincing hiding and snaky I know the
Italian Italian government aren't too
happy with you and your Italian RS at
the moment yeah they tried to take me
off the radio was early early on my
Wi-Fi cut out midc Court I was getting
knocks on the door they're trying to
silence me man um my my first main
takeaway from this game was gez the the
second rendition of the French national
anthem in the crowd is getting earlier
and earlier every week they pretty much
like did an oncore this week like the
national anthem straight in the kickoff
off straight into round two um but like
man these French atmospheres just look
next level at the moment like I'm seeing
footage on ITV of battered French BLS
with like pints and cigarettes hanging
out their mouth in the crowd like when
they get up and they score points it
just looks like such a great place to be
um in terms of Italy like guys they just
have zero ability to stop a team when
they get any kind of momentum or quick
ball like if France got quick ball first
phase you could almost just put your
house on they're going to score within
the next three to five phases similar to
the New Zealand game they Italy just
seriously lack that like size and
genuine physicality to be able to kill
momentum once it starts um and once the
French team got up there was just like a
snowball effect that r that rolling
momentum of France they just they look
so passive they they they couldn't get
anything going in this game again Lads
not a great tournament for them at all
yeah I think they've probably been the
most disappointing team in the whole
world cup maybe along with Aussie as
well but um Aussie weren't coping the
hidings quite like Italy and the way you
talk them up at the start of the
competition I thought you know we might
have been quite nervous um going into
that game but they weren't weren't never
a chance they were like one of the miniz
yeah but but if you put Australia in
this group do you think Australia could
cop a 60 point 70 point hiding from
France New Zealand as well and probably
yes and I also think Italy are such a
confidence-based team that the those
guys need confidence to play well so
much if you'd put them in the group
instead of Australia with Wales like
maybe they do get maybe they do get
going and get some momentum and then we
see a different team but it doesn't
matter is that's all hypothetical now
they didn't show up at all at this
tournament and they made me look a fo on
the water lad show so I've got no time
I've got no time for them maybe Aussie
should play Italy this weekend for the
worst team disappointing team at the
Rugby World Cup that would be that would
be some press conference Eddie Jes
before we have to get early into that
he's coaching Japan mate he won't even
show up he's not
interested unbelievable if he's off to
Japan that's absolutely unbelievable um
Aussie have made an absolute meal there
getting rid of one of the best coaches
and Dave Ry yeah for Eddie Jones to
Absolute make a debacle of the whole
situation and the Rugby World Cup super
disappointing but anyway get on to the
Rugby World Cup review we've got Wales
vers Georgia
4319 Wales ended up being far too good
for Georgia what' you make of this one
suy I was a bit nervous for Wales Hing
in just because of the late news like
when Anin pulled out no damn bigger and
then the history there Georgia bet them
the last time they played and I just
thought this like stages set for Georgia
who are just like a physical side love
the wrestle in the forward pack they're
just going to make this a real boring
encounter and Come Away with the points
so it wasn't the most entertaining game
to watch but credit to Wales like they
found a way to win it comfortably
without their two best Playmakers and it
kind of shows the credit and the
leadership they've got in the squad now
like they lost fatel as a result which
is massive for them but they look like a
team at the moment that's found their
identity a bit and they may not be the
best team going around in the world cup
but they know what they're good at and
they've got a few key players that can
carry them to wins so I'm interested to
see how they go this week but Georgia
for me as a whole throughout this
competition I think we've spoken about
it a bit like I probably overhype them
in terms of my expectations I thought
the recent results have been really good
and they were going to be one of these
sides that would Target a Wales A FG and
oie and triy pull off an upset there
Unfortunately they couldn't and it was
more your portugals and stuff the teams
that did that so I think this next World
Cup cycle for them is going to be really
interesting hey because the under 20s
have been amazing as of late so the got
some real talent and depth there now
they just need quality opposition
throughout this next four years and they
could form into like a Powerhouse they
just need the high level regular
football so fingers crossed they get
that because in a way they were
disappointing and they were kind of the
Georgia we've seen from the past I think
they're better than that yeah I'm with
you I thought we were going to get at
least one upet from them but even in
that game that they were in there with
Wales even with 20 to go it looked like
it could have gone either way Wales did
score three tries in the last 13 minutes
which definitely blew the score line out
but I think that game was a lot closer
than um the sco score line suggested so
um yeah I'm with you I think Georgia
going forward are still going to be a
very competitive team and they're only
going to get better over the next four
years and I know how closely he watched
their 20 side um over the past few years
purist though I've got a sign poster on
the way from their Academy a I can't
wait to it'll be in the background
hopefully by the final episode of this
podcast cuz yeah it's fair to say I'm
getting into my uh Georgian wrestling
it's huge you'll be getting on the
futures for Georgia to win the 2027
Rugby World Cup in Australia the
conditions will suit and yeah I'm
thinking 31 in America they're going to
Target that one you know cuz they always
say it you got to lose one to win one so
I think they'll lose the final in Aussie
and then they'll win it in America bit
closer to home well I'll keep this clip
just in case that does happen and you
will be the true Oracle to be the
greatest it'll take the Ethan black out
of one since he's not playing this
weekend you'll be the new Guru but the
next game was England versus S and gee
was Jake The Snake England just sneak
through in this one against the star
mowans was good to watch but um what did
you make of it yeah good to watch for
you boys maybe Lads um look it I mean it
started well geez it started well the
first try was brilliant nicely worked
shape they generated quick ball from the
first forward part a little tip we've
not seen a lot of that from England
getting behind the scene identified the
space played to the space straight away
turning the corner on the edge executing
on the edge scoring the corner I was
like we're on we're we're back we we're
going to win the World Cup again I was
like that Chilean performance with the
Line in the Sand for us we're back this
is 2019 World Cup England I was I was
all for it and then for the next 70
minutes boys we literally did [__]
nothing uh this was really really hard
to watch I think um I let's be very
clear like some should have won this
game like unquestionably somewh should
have won this game yes there were some
things out of their control reasons why
they didn't win the game I think the the
disallowed try obviously and then
everyone spoken about the yellow card I
think the yellow card was harsh but it
was for team infringement so I kind of
understand where the referee is coming
from but then in terms of stuff in their
control like even with those two
refereeing decisions I've just spoken
about Samoa should still win this game
um like that that Danny care try from
first phase like like you're six points
up in a test match you're defending a
goal line scrum yes I understand you're
down a yellow card you're down to 14 men
but like you you can't allow the nine to
run and score untouched under the sticks
with a six-point lead first phase not
even forcing the skill like we've seen
how difficult it is for England to
string two passes together at times like
make them at least throw three passes
score in the corner and then make old
mate kick the goal from the touch line
to take the lead um if there's any of my
old teammates listening to this they'll
probably be absolutely pissing
themselves laughing right now because I
literally did the exact same thing in a
European Cup game once a couple of years
ago but I took an absolute hiding for it
for about three years and boys still
send me the clip Boys still send me the
clip on the anniversary the defense
coach didn't speak to me for about a
year and a half so and he hasn't played
since yeah I literally I've literally
been I've been running water for four
years because I did that in Bon once in
the European Cup so if I'm taking that
hiding for it then Samar have got to and
then even at the end that they they had
the chance to go and take the game they
just you know they they had the ball in
in deep in England's half and you're
just thinking like just be patient keep
possession build multiphase because if
you get over 10 phases there's a decent
chance you're going to get an advantage
and once you have an advantage have a
crack for the try see if you can score
and if not kick the goal to try and
steal the win but then just trying to
force the offload to score like you
don't have to score first phase last
play of the game when you're in the red
just take England deep get it to 10 15
phases if you can um so Samoa should be
like it was a good performance but they
should be feeling really disappointed
that they didn't win this game because
it was there for the taken yeah mate I
love hearing you talk about England
games look how excited you get every
week it's like my favorite part of this
show is you reviewing an England game
and I'm looking forward to you
previewing this weekend against Fiji who
should in theory should be a bit tougher
than SAR but even they haven't been as
convincing the last few weeks so it's
going to be an interesting old battle
there but the next game was Ireland V
Scotland and wow I watched this game an
absolute a watching the Irish run their
attack and their game they just had
everything nailed what did you make of
this game Sly yeah it's not often you
watch a game of rugby and just get hit
with like a massive feeling of anxiety
because you know that your team is
taking on this Irish side the next week
like I'd hype this game up I thought
Scotland were going to we we all agreed
irand were going to win but I thought
Scotland were going to push them I think
I said like six to 10 points it'll be a
tight game Scotland will be up for it
man Ireland like just how good are they
it's crazy what 31 nil at halftime a
complete domination in the first half
and the game's over like watching them
play as well it's not just their ability
to score points it's how they do it like
they're such a pleasure to watch I think
they're a team that if you love rugby
you can't not like them which makes them
more frustrating cuz on both sides of
the ball they're just so good like
defensively they're a joy to watch and
I'm a first five I hate tackling but
just watching them do it makes it look
fun and then when they get the ball in
the hand like their ability to play
phases their shape is like textbook
shape they remind me of like the penr
Panthers if you watch the NRL like they
just have so much time they have Ford
Runners running great lines they can rip
it out the back to six if Bundy ke is
not breaking the line then they've
always got bailout options and if things
go wrong in their shape they just find a
way to problem solve it within like 2 to
3 seconds and then they're back into
their work they're so good to watch and
saying that I was talking to snaky
before about it it's like Scotland gave
them way too much time to be able to
control the game and we were talking
about the All Blacks and what they need
to do and obviously straight away that's
one thing is cutting down the amount of
time 6on and the ball Runners have to
make up decisions but at the same time
like good good sides and good players
make themselves time they find a way to
do that and Island keep doing that week
in and week out so I'm hoping for a bit
of complacency or something but man I
was so nervous watching that game like
even my wife was like [__] these guys
are mean and I was like yeah they are
yeah M absolutely naed it they just so
they're pretty much good at everything
they there hard to find a real weakness
in their game and it wasn't like
Scotland were really bad either like
Finn Russell was throwing a lot of
attacking at options at them like jeez
he's got a nice long ball he like he was
shaping for cross kicks checking a real
wide flat ball um just throwing a lot of
um different attacking plays at them but
their D was just so solid and it wasn't
until they sort of started resting guys
that things really started to um holes
really start to open up for Scotland
because it could have been a lot bigger
score than even that score line suggest
it probably was favorable to Scotland
even though it was an absolute hiding
but yep like you say fair bit of anxiety
watching that game but we'll get to the
preview part of it in a little bit um so
we'll go to the next game which is Japan
vers Argentina now this was a good game
Snake actually got up and watched this
one it was impressive um both sides gave
it a real good crack Japan looked like
they were potentially going to win the
swamp but Argentina just too good what'
you make of it yeah Lads there were some
absolute worldly scores in this game
weren't there I mean don't get me wrong
the defense was very very optional at
times but like boys I'm more than happy
to see that kind of like old school back
and forth like you score we score you
score we score um it was brilliant to
watch did you boys see that first Japan
try that that must that must be the best
second row try of all time chip and
Chase he used to be a Winger apparently
he's really fast at SCH is he is he a
kiwi yeah he grew up over here right
okay but let's be honest we were all
fast at school mate that's the go-to
line no CH no chance Jimmy was FAS
school not a chance I only got fast when
I started to squat heavy oh debatable
that's never happened is it when have
you been under the bar mate Jesus
exactly I never got fast no this was a
really enjoyable game like I said
defense was optional at times but some
some really clinical attack and nice to
see the RGS turn up and play some of
that um sort of like attacking flare
style of rugby we've seen from them for
the last two years and Gees there's
nothing I love more than an Argentina
score because it's it's chest pumps it's
pointing at people in the out it's red
in the face like those boys just love it
don't they they are so passionate and if
they can get rolling this week like they
definitely we obviously I I don't want
to touch too much on the previews but if
they get going this week they they have
a better Squad than Wales um so I just I
just want to see those guys cooking like
like you said Jim it was a a good game
you know 70 minutes it was 297 so this
was a proper game you could watch right
down to the end and then last 10 minutes
Ireland uh sorry uh Argentina just took
it comfortably I think they had a score
and then they kicked a goal and then
kind of cruised Cruis through the last
10 minutes but really really enjoyable
game to watch and there was a lot of
consequence on the line you know it's
easy to forget that Japan could have
gone through if they'd won this game so
70 minutes I was really really enjoying
it really really nice watch yeah to be
fair like Japan at the start of the
tournament we sort of wrote them off um
pretty early but um they ended up
playing some pretty good footy at the
back end of that competition and like
you say not too far away from even
qualifying for a quarterfinal which
would have been a good achievement for
them so I'm not the worst Rugby World
Cup for them in the end but um obviously
just not too good to make the
quarterfinals next game was Tonga vers
Romania um gez the Tongans look tired in
this game they've had some big boys play
some big minutes and um started to look
a little bit nervous for them for a
while but um they just had too much
strike power the likes of George MOA who
was a great pickup for me and my fantasy
team he he he got a big score was
breaking tackles for fun but they just
had too much strike power in the
backline really what did you make of it
sirle yeah pretty much what you said
right like for me Tonga I think we've
said it quite a few times you know but
this is the team on paper that could
have been anything but just didn't quite
pull it together they're probably
another side like your portugals and
that I mentioned before like they just
need to be playing regular high quality
games with the squad that they've got
cuz they have so many players playing in
Europe and stuff it's really hard for
them to assemble their top team together
frequently so hopefully that that
International World r calendar that they
keep talking about can actually happen
and they can do that more often and like
you said George MOA like makes you
wonder if he was there from the start of
the tournament just how different things
could have been like well he got 10
weeks down to five it was a pretty bad
tackle but was it that bad like maybe if
it was a two three we ban then things
could have been a little different and
they might have pushed them teams a
little more because he had a massive
impact straight away on them but yeah a
real shame for Tonga probably not the
campaign they were after they show
glimpses of it but yeah fatigue all that
kind of stuff they're just not quite
there with the top teams and now I see
Portugal and that have jumped them in
the world rankings as well so that's
probably like the ultimate blow for them
as well it's crazy to believe he if you
thought about that at the start of the
year but just watching that game I just
the biggest thing I noticed was the
probably the conditioning of the side
like no one was putting in those little
extra efforts which makes make teams
great like the kick Chase was so poor no
one was ever putting pressure on um
anyone when they were kicking and just
all those little efforts weren't part of
their game so and they were so reliant
on people to break the line which you
know you can't be a successful team just
chasing those sort of plays so um tough
yeah like you say tough tournament for
Tonga but um hopefully get a few more
games in over the next four years and
they'll be a lot better team um going
forward and hopefully they get a few
more guys um jump over to their country
as well like the likes of Nani laar who
I know was only a few days short um from
being able to beat this world cup which
obviously would be would make a little
bit of a difference for them as well but
hopefully they can grow from there but
the next game was Fiji vers Portugal and
this was one of the special moments of
this Rugby World Cup on two two counts
really Fiji obviously qualified into the
quarterfinals and Portugal winning their
first ever Rugby World Cup um what a
game what did you make of it sirly yeah
this was the ideal result heading in
right wasn't it like I think we all
wanted Fiji to pick up the bonus point
and get the win but at the same time how
cool would it be for Portugal to get
their first Rugby World Cup win and I
kind of expected Fiji to be way too good
I think we had them both 13 plus right
to get the win but Portugal just showed
how much it means to them like they're a
team that's fueled on pess like I think
snaky spoked before about Argentina like
Portugal will like hold my bear they
were like kissing each other when they
were scoring they were that first and
then you see them get back to the
airport I don't know if you guys have
seen those clips but man that looks like
one of the greatest nightclubs ever but
it's just at the airport and it's just a
whole bunch of lads singing songs and
celebrating the win like you couldn't
help but be so chuff for them I think
the way in which they won as well like
they played a beautiful brand of rugby
to watch and Fiji gave it their all they
threw a lot of stuff at them I think we
saw a bit of fatigue in FG again and I
think this loss will be great for them
because they probably had that banana
skin loss in them that we've spoken
about a bit as well and this was it but
they still got what they needed I do
wonder if because they've had such
important pool games against the Wes
against Aussie against Wales they've had
to roll out a real similar 23 every time
so are we seeing that the result of that
now and a bit of fatigue coming to their
play but yeah great for Portugal and
great for World rugby like when you see
teams introduced to the competition this
is what you dream of them doing
Unfortunately they probably weren't as
many of these results that people would
want in a world cup but this one alone
gives you enough faith that we can be a
global game at some time within the next
couple of World Cups so just unreal
scenes yeah 100% And I love the way the
Portuguese defended they they were just
throwing their bodies into everything
like I don't I think that was probably
the least amount of tackle breaks the
Fijian side have had this Rugby World
Cup they generally rely on you know a
couple of broken tackles break bust the
line get an offload and score but the
Portuguese were just flying into them
and they they all worked hard and um it
showed some real good ticker and it was
one of those real passionate
performances that you know as a if
you're sitting back in Portugal watching
rugby for the first time you'd be bloody
proud watching that and potentially
these young kids over there will pick up
the rugby ball and give that a go
instead of put down their Ronaldo top
and um pick up a Martin top with a
number seven on it would be pretty
special to see so um but speaking of
Martins like who was your guys stand out
of the pool play who um has obviously
left not someone who's not staying on
like Martens was one for me he obviously
um scored a heap of points in fantasy I
don't know how heavy he is he looks
about 80 kgs as a seven but jeez he
throws his frame around makes a lot of
tackles dangerous on the edge he was
someone that I viously knew nothing
about going into this tournament but
left the tournament warning and Martin
top with number seven on the back who
who was your snake I boys I did think
about trying to pick an Italian player
as a joke but I even I can't do that
like I'm [__] so done with those
fellas after they're coming for you bro
they're coming for you I know I know BR
honestly every time the buzzer goes off
and they on the edge um I think um for
me the the obvious one is surly's old
mate Finn Russell like you Jim you spoke
about how he played against Ireland uh
the weekend and I I just want to see
that Razzle in a World Cup quarterfinal
because I
think him in that Scotland team for a
quarterfinal or or even a semi-final
with a favorable matchup would have been
one game where I thought a big upset
could be on the cards because if that
guy gets hot like he they can put 30
points on a team before they've even
woken up um that was the kind of the big
obvious one for me the slightly less
obvious one was the guy flagged up
before was the for Samoa like oh boys
this week against England he was an
absolute Beast I obviously mentioned
these at Saron um so easy game for him
to get up up for playing against some of
his teammates maybe maybe he'd had an
argument with farell in training as well
and he wanted to get into him but yeah
he he man he he is fantastic and he's
been one of the best players in England
over the last 18 months so to see him
kick on and do it in test matches as
well made me uh made me really happy
yeah that was one of the calls that you
made from the start which that did sort
of come true one of the one of the few
where you you talk them up and his
performances have actually boys I'm two
up against you for predictions please
stop pushing this
narrative this is fake news I see you
nodding along I think both of us have
probably taken your guy yeah well um
just snaky even when we lose we find a
way to win mate so you just got to deal
with it but yeah I was even going to use
the gag of swapping in a Cristiano
Ronaldo 7 for a Martin 7 so you've used
all my jokes um then I was going to
throw snaky some credit with Theo there
and then he's gone and done that but
like to be honest I don't know how I
hadn't seen much of this guy play and
watching him play what a weapon like one
of an unreal loose forward to watch so
that was a great shout I'll stick with
Portugal and the hooker I think it's
teder when he dropped it on the boot
like the fact he was and people say he
was out of position being lazy but he's
obviously just got one of the great
rugby brains so he could read where the
nudge was coming he thought look my
fullback my Wingers are out of position
here I'm going to drop back in cover the
boys and then just as casual as you like
just just pass halfway finds a perfect
touch jogs up to halfway as if it was
just another day at the office like that
was one of the great nudges I've had a
few mates that play professional rugby
that are hookers that have tried to kick
the ball and it's come off their Shin so
well done to them you know that was a
nudge that was something I could see off
sir's big right foot planing for North
Harbor in a few years that was
impressive to watch but I'll give you a
quick Round Up of my fantasy team I
thought I had a really good week last
week obviously Captain will Jordan he
got 103 points so 206 Leicester massive
week 106 points for him poo went good
MOA went good so a few of my outside
backs our dmac as well 82 points few of
my backs went really good so um fors
were okay they all sort of did their job
but nothing too special there but I
thought I was going to climb up the
water lead rankings but I noticed that
most people listen to the podcast and
have captained and picked pretty similar
guys to what I have so I haven't moved
up at all I'm still in 10th place but I
did climb up the world rankings so
obviously everyone in this waterl pool
is going up the world rankings pretty
fast listening to this podcast but
looking forward to this week man it is
tough to find some fantasy rugby players
who are really going to stand out all
the games are so even I'm not really
sure what to do obviously the teams
still aren't named yet we only know
irand and the All Blacks but um it's an
absolute blowout that we can't get the
teams named earlier yeah well I think
this has been your biggest bone to pick
since we first met and I jumped on the
Pod M I think it was one of the first
things you brought up it's like yeah it
just grinds my gears right because it
would make things so much easier for
everyone and obviously the players get
told on the Monday leading into the week
so they've already picked the team they
know what's happening so why they don't
share it just with the public then and
and make something cool of it like the
NRL do team lless Tuesday you know 600
p.m. every Tuesday night you tune in to
see who's playing for your team like
something like that on a Wednesday or
even a Thursday would be unreal but for
some reason rugby just hasn't got around
it yeah no it definitely breaks me and
with with everyone's complaining about
the teams being leaked Etc and how
they're going to stop it you stop it by
naming the team earlier so it doesn't
have to be leaked and everyone gets to
see the team and pump up some of the
matchups that we're we're looking
forward to like it's hard to be able to
pump up a game when you don't even know
who's playing obviously Ireland have
named their team a little bit earlier
they went a day earlier this week so um
shout out to Andy Farrell for doing all
the fantasy players a huge favor but our
mate Russy like he's been naming his
team a couple of days early all
tournament and now he's pulled back and
gone right back so he's playing mine
games with all the fantasy players as
well and it's doing my head in but
speaking of fantasy going forward to
this week you will all get a whole
reload of boosters so you'll get another
triple Captain to use kicker booster as
well as the defender king or whatever it
is so um use those wisely I'd highly
recommend not to use your triple Captain
this weekend I think there's going to be
some big scores in the semi-finals next
week so that's my advice to you guys I
think there'll be no one getting a huge
score that's my prediction no one will
be getting in the 80 points this week um
in the quarterfinals so going to have to
Choose Wisely and like I said I'm not
sure who it is I'm going to go someone
who I think is a fantasy gun
potentially um a Lester off the top of
my head or a will Jordan um but even
some of those guys not too sure but
we'll get into the preview cuz we have
four of the best games um you could Pro
possibly predict really um so even so
hard to predict we went through these
games actually two weeks ago so if you
want to go back and listen to that we've
already already sort of done these but
times might have changed over these last
two games and we'll start with the first
game of the week Wales vers
Argentina oh what are we going here boys
flip a coin almost for me let's start
with you snake and I'll finish no mate
I've literally got the the what you just
said written down in red on my screen I
think uh this this quarterfinal matchup
set is ridiculous hey like you could
make four genuinely decent picks based
on all the evidence you've seen and get
four results wrong
yeah there could be there could be four
southern hemisphere teams in the
semi-final there could be four Northern
Hemisphere teams in the semi-final and
there could be anything in between um
and I don't think anything sums that up
better than this Wales Argentina game
this is an absolute coin toss for me I
think um in terms of Wales the the
tournament has already been a massic
success for them they've won their poll
unbeaten and I mentioned the first time
I came on with dads like on the backdrop
of the last 18 months Wales domestically
internationally they're they're four the
the the structural and funding issues
that they've had like to get to where
they're at now is already a huge success
and I'm going to tip Wales because I
will always go with form and what I've
seen in the tournament um above talent
and ability I would say I do think
Argentina have a better Squad if you if
you put the the two groups of players
next to each other I think I'm picking
most of the Argentina guys um position
for position um but just just on form
that we've seen at this world cup and
then the confidence you know that Wales
have won all their games they clutched
out some big wins they think about now
you know how much will that um Last
Stand defensive set that they had
against Fiji to get the to get the job
done have set them up to be successful
in knockout rugby um and like we've
mentioned Argentina have been a touch
disappointing but if the Argentina turn
up and get hot they could blow him out
so this this game I who knows man who
knows I'm going to go Wales but can can
see it going either way nice who are you
going sirley yeah I'm I'm going to go
Wales as well but much like snaky said
it and you said it it is a coin toss I
think Pablo's out for Argentina so
that's a massive loss and then I heard
the Welsh coach saying that Dan biger is
going to start and that enum should be
sweet so that for me kind of pushes them
ahead I I think they'll just be too good
and they'll grind it out again we keep
saying Argentina haven't quite been the
team that we'd H so yeah I think Wales
will win this one but I'm predicting it
will be the last win they have at this
world cut but I think it's going to be a
really tight game like everyone keeps
saying you know these pools they've dhed
up some biased quarterfinals and whatnot
but when you look at the matchups like
snaky was saying they're actually
perfect for each other like it's just a
shame that that's the way it's played
out but this is going to be a great game
I I'll get up and watch it for sure I
think it's going to be really close um I
I'll back Wales yeah but you could
convince me otherwise yeah oh me too
like I feel like literally could make a
case with either of them but I'm with
with you I think it's going to be a
really close game I also think it's
going to be low scoring I think it's
going to be some sort of like a penalty
penalty off really we'll have bigger
kicking goals and Bali for Argentina
both trying to smack them over so I
think it's just going to come down to
whoever's got probably got the best
discipline or he's playing the right end
of the field and getting these turning
these penalties into three points I'm
picking sort of like a 15 18 type score
and um like like we've said it could go
either way but I am going to go
Argentina so Against the Grain for you
guys and um get the first win for the
southern hemisphere but the next game is
obviously oh man this is this is the one
we've been waiting for New Zealand the
mighty All Blacks I've got my jersey on
I'm repping already um against the
mighty Irish who man have been the most
impressive team in this tournament 17
wins on the Trot I think I'm right in
saying not far off the world record like
they are that good um what are we going
here suly well I'm hoping that they
still battle in quarterfinals they can't
get past the stage and that we can trip
them up I think it's going to be a heck
of a game obviously a lot of people
reference to when Ireland came here and
bet us last year for the first time and
won that series but when you look back
at the team we had last year like Jordy
was at 15 I think bod was at 10 Richie
moang was on the bench our whole front
rows kind of changed list the F just
made us International debut we had guys
like Quin toy at 12 so so much has
changed for the All Blacks Jason Ryan's
come in to coach and really flip that
forward pack on its head as well in
terms of mindset and attitude so I'll
always back the All Blacks against
anyone so that's alone is why I'm saying
that all blacks but I just wish this
game was the final because I feel like
Ireland 100% can beat us and if they do
you're almost not guttered because
island is so good but then you're
guttered because it's so so early in the
tournament and going out in the
quarterfinal in the history box looks so
bad when losing to Ireland really isn't
that bad so we're going to have to be at
our best and we're going to have to make
Ireland not play to their best CU I
think if both teams do play at 100% the
Irish probably get us but I'll back us
to have something up Our Sleeve Joe
Schmid would have been in the lab so
yeah it's going to be a heck of a watch
either way oh man is going to be some
game and I I did read that I think this
is the fourth time ever since the tab
have started that the All Blacks are
going into a game not as favorite so it
doesn't happen often um they've won a
few of those times so they did go into
the games as underdogs but um
unbelievable stats and think that the
All Blacks have only not been favorites
four times in in that long it just goes
to show the sort of dominance or the
bias the New Zealand um punters have
with the black Jersey but snaky
obviously you're going to bring a bit of
reality to us here aren't you you're a
northern hemisphere
Guru what have you got for me yeah look
Jim I think Ireland so far I think we're
all clear in agreement that Ireland have
been the outstanding team at the
tournament so far man they're just
they're they're so well coached they're
so well organized and they just have
like unparalleled Clarity in what
they're trying to do they're definitely
not the most talented Squad of
individuals I think if you you put that
Squad up I I genuinely believe there are
three squads that probably have a better
group of players in terms of raw
individual player ability but just the
the way that they're coached and
organized is it's outrageous and you you
know look there's obviously the factor
again I spoke with Sly about this
earlier that almost all of the Squad
plays for one or two teams one of two
teams and the vast majority of the Squad
plays for lster so they have that
natural um cohesion and the consistency
that some of these other teams just
don't have the luxury of having the
amount of time that these Lads spend on
the field together is outrageous um but
yeah it's a credit to faroh and his
coaching team man that the place that
he's got this group into to for an Irish
side to
be number one ranked team in the world
and going into a quarterfinal as the All
Blacks as pretty strong favorites like
don't get me wrong boys the All Blacks
can win this game um and my my reasoning
for that is the All Blacks have come hot
just at the right time I think if you
give me this game six weeks ago I'm
shutting you boys down straight away
like lad you have no chance it's done
already but the last few weeks I do feel
the ORS have turned Corner in their
performance I think um obviously got
some guys back fit Jordy back in
Midfield makes the backline look
different um but it definitely is a real
game like Ireland are definitely
favorites New Zealand are definitely
underdogs that's 100% the case but both
teams can win this game um I think for
me it just depends how much defensive
pressure New Zealand can create on
Ireland shape we we we watched Scotland
this week and like if you just stay
connected and you don't get up and take
any space away from this island team man
like they are too good at running that
shape Scotland what they did is they sat
off and they let guys like seon ringrose
like turn the corner and get into that
space outside from playing out the back
of a pod inside and once he gets into
that space on the outside it's just like
it's domino effect like everyone has to
jam in and then they just rip you apart
I don't see the All Blacks doing that I
think the All Blacks are one of the
teams who can create serious internal
pressure on the island in shape and if
they can disrupt the the timing and the
flow of seon and ringrose the guys who
have connected out the back of those
pods they can cause Ireland some serious
problems the other the other thing New
Zealand have to show for them to to to
be able to get over the line in this
game is they have to find a way of
playing when they don't generate the
quick ball that they want we've spoken
about it before but against Ireland if
if New Zealand get into a rhythm of same
way carry same way Collision same way
Collision this iseland team they work
too hard they're too connected they're
too physical you're never going to
generate any quick ball and that's when
I think the All Blacks might start to
look a bit lost like we saw against
France if the All Blacks can build a
two-sided attack to their shape and have
the option to change direction I do
think Ireland are vulnerable down short
sides they leave Gibson park down short
sides by himself quite a lot with with
the with the Winger back on a half and a
forward if they can take the short sides
and rebuild them maybe new newand can
regenerate momentum and once New Zealand
get momentum boys it's all better off
because that's when of the best team in
the world just quickly on there like um
while I was watching the game Italy on
cuz we were sitting up so high you got
kind of bird's eye view of the game and
obviously we were dominating Italy but I
was really impressed with the amount of
work moang Jordi Barett and bod were
doing sweeping round to the short side
and it was something I've never noticed
in the All Blacks play like the amount
of time that the bodies were in motion
coming Back Against the Grain for the
short side and I just wonder if like Joe
Schmid they all talk about how he breaks
down the game so well and he encourages
them to play to space I wonder if that's
kind of been the plan the whole time is
identifying that island or some of these
top sides that they're going to come up
against don't mark up so well on that
short side and they started implementing
it then because I personally had never
seen an all black backline move so much
off the ball and stack a short side so
often so that's a great point there from
snaky and hopefully that's why we were
doing it then and we see it on Sunday
yeah and it's winning that game line as
well like you said snaky like if they
can win that gain line win that
breakdown and get that quick ball we
we've seen how good they are when there
is space out there and they are playing
on top on front football so they'll be
playing off the back of Leicester
carries over the gain line getting quick
ball and then hopefully unleashing uh
the Richie mangas and Jordi barretts
with time and if they do get that they
will be hard to stop but I'm with you
snake I think the shape that um Ireland
run is going to pose a hell of a threat
for our Edge defense which is one thing
which I I don't think the All Blacks
have nailed yet is the the way they're
defending on the edges they're defending
passive I know you felt like they could
put irand under pressure but they're
going to have to completely change what
they've been doing for the last couple
of years cuz at the moment their Wingers
and midfielders a defending passive and
I think that will play into Irish hands
um when they coming around the corner
with their um guys on their shoulder
squaring up um makes it really hard to
defend if you're not putting them under
pressure so um that's the biggest
probably concern for me um it's going to
be a massive day for Leicester and will
Jordan to get their um EDD sorted um and
like with Leicester playing we're going
to rely a lot on him for his game line
carries and I guess the other thing is
the kicking game as well how they kick
in this game is going to be have a
massive influence whether they're just
going to kick early like they had did
against France or whether they're going
to look to try and play a bit and then
try and find a few better kicks than
what they did in that game when they
just resorted to first phase kicks and
um didn't really get much reward from it
so oh mate I'm excited this is going to
be some game cannot wait till 8:00
Sunday morning New Zealand time and um
sit down nervous as watching this game
with my all work top on so oh what a
game we'll be able to get to the next
one England versus Fiji here we go snake
yeah you can get really excited how why
England winning
this um look for me Lads this game is in
fiji's hands like Fiji have this game
and if they want it they can win this
game a 100% wow M 100%
because if they stay in control of their
emotions they stay disciplined the set
piece goes okay and they they don't let
the occasion get the better of them
right now they are the better rugby team
they are playing better rugby and
outside of those things I just mentioned
ill discipline set peace I I just don't
see how England get in the game I I
don't know where our where our where our
possession and where our scores are
coming from in in open field play it it
just I I'm I'm lost for words Lads like
between the two 22s I just don't we
don't offer anything um and defensively
we're trying to do this this like narrow
aggressive defense sort of trying to do
what I said the All Blacks need to do
against Ireland by creating pressure but
it's kind you could kind of see the lads
aren't convinced on it so they they're
in this shape to come and bring super
aggressive line speed but then they kind
of get three quarters of the way there
and then cool their Jets a bit and they
end up being in this position where
they're narrow and in a position to be
aggressive but they're not following
through and it's just so easy to get
round them sometimes we saw Samoa score
off a cross kick again this weekend and
I think to somewhere where England have
looked really vulnerable for a long time
and the other issue is when they're
defending like that like if Fiji make a
half break and get their arms through
England a dust um and one thing we know
is guaranteed for Fiji in this big game
when they're fired up is that old mate's
going to get his arms through the line
get get through and then there's going
to be five five Fijian jerseys around
the ball and uh and I just I I I really
want to Lad like I I don't want to beat
up on but I I don't I don't see how we
win this game and like I again I said to
to surle when we were talking this
morning like I am torn here Lads because
of course I want England to win of
course I want England to win but I also
want to see teams rewarded for playing
good positive attacking rugby and teams
rewarded with wins for rugby that gets
me excited to watch rugby and right now
that's Fiji and that's not England and
Fiji deserve the opportunity to go to a
semi-final and Express themselves and
show the world how rugby can be played
and England don't and that's the that's
the like harsh reality of it and I think
long term for England getting hiding
this week could be the only thing that
helps us turn the corner because if we
win this game and we go to a World Cup
semi-final I think a few people keep
their jobs and it it papers over the
cracks of what's been a bleak 18 months
for English rugby and I think it just
encourages us to keep doing the same
thing the only thing that encourages
serious change for our style of players
to get hiding from a team that plays
complete 180 of us complete opposite
side of rugby I mean what do you L
reckon you're going to be Fiji get up
aren't you geez I was I honestly was not
expecting that I was expecting you to be
hard up England Fiji just lost to
Portugal snake you're telling me they're
the form team in the competition no no
no they're not the for they're not the
form team in the
competition but I just click bait
clickbait mat if you clip me up and you
bring up Italy one more
time oh jeez now I am Keen to hear your
opinion though um suly what where do you
see this game because like England are
favorites in this one yeah England are
favorites but I don't know listening to
snaky talk convinces me more and more
like I thought I was being a bit silly
just you know head over heart like all
that kind of jazz because obviously
being a a mutual fan here you want Fiji
to win because they' been one of the
great success stories for me and the
point snaky risers it's a really valid
one is England at the out of the comp
they were just playing a kicking game
going up in threes Ford was using his
skill set to get them wins now with this
feral decision they've gone away from
that and I just to me that was their
best method of winning that's how they
were winning games and we just thought
look this is how they're going to go
through the World Cup they'll make their
way through to a semifinal just killing
teams that are not disciplined against
them the kicking game's going to be spot
on and they'll just make their hay off
errors now with farell there they've
kind of diverted away from that and I
don't think they know how they're going
to play now theyve Chuck Marcus Smith at
the back and he's like a Damen McKenzie
style of footballer but I don't think
the way that England play is going to
suit him at all so I feel like yeah they
don't know their identity at the moment
whereas fij know exactly how the way
they want to play they have the
confidence of having beaten England
before and I think they had that loss
they've needed to wake them up that
they're going to be fired up for this
one so I I really hope fij can pull off
if my house was on it I would put it on
England but I I do think there's a
genuine chance fij win this game and
again much like Wales it'll probably be
the last game that they win throughout
this tournament but what a success that
would be like Fiji and a semi final I
just really hope they can pull it off M
it's definitely a game I'll be getting
up for I cannot wait to see this one I
think it's going to be such a good game
I think it's afternoon game over there
so it'll probably suit a little bit
faster running we'll be hotter
conditions which might suit Fiji as well
but I see this game being decided by the
breakdown which is going to be btia um
to a over over the ball when they're
over the ball and they're getting
rewarded Fiji will play off that um
either straight off that or off the
penalty and they'll get into the game if
those attempted turnovers CU they're
very aggressive at the breakdown they
almost go for everything if they're
penalized there then I think they'll
lose this game and I think England will
go up in threes off the back of that and
just control the game and strangle fij
so I think a lot of the work's going to
come down to how accurate they are at
the breakdown getting these turnovers
and um because if they do get them and
they're playing off that turnover ball
we all know how dangerous Fiji are so um
I think Bia is going to be a key man for
them and hopefully he shows the referee
a clear release gets his hands on the
ball one pull just like the rules say
and um I think it's the um French
referee yeah it is R now it could be
some more tier one bias like how s were
robbed he
snaky I don't know boys I've never met a
French fell who's going to favor England
so oh true Fe coal right boys you you
got to get your predictions out though
I'm not letting you boys Dodge this one
I need I need hard confirm who's winning
so who are you going I'm gonna go Fiji
but I just just cover my own back here
England can win this game no we just
want we just want a hard we just want a
hard Choice man sorry sorry sorry sorry
I'm scared you're gonna clip me up again
so you're going Fiji sir's going England
no I'm going fij Oh I thought you said
if you put your house on it you go
England yeah but the house isn't on it
I'm on
fij that oh I've said it's a b breakdown
um battle bot is going to show some
clear pictures so FG for me as well wow
all three of us $350 Outsiders there you
go um fij to win okay in the last game
now this could be a World Cup finals W
what what game we've got the privilege
of watching this weekend South Africa
the absolute bullies the most physical
team in the competition up against
France with the Return of the King best
play on the planet Dupont will be back
out there with the Mars I cannot wait
for this game either 8:00 Monday morning
does not get any better where are we
seeing this one sirle yeah this is one
that could go either way and again is
probably worthy of being a final right
and like this is the perfect narrative
for a game you got the host taking on
the defending champs both sides playing
some great football dep pont's back like
you mentioned he's going to he was
wearing head gear at training I saw he's
doing everything he's ready to go then
you got Russy and Co just barking from
the South African Camp as well like the
atmosphere at this game is going to be
crazy I don't think the players will be
able to hear each other at all on the
field and it's just going to come down
to instincts and whatever team's more
structured and organized so I'm going to
back South Africa I think the Pollard's
boot is going to be the difference I
expect him to start again we don't know
the starting team but I think he'll be
in the 10 Jersey and yeah I just like
what I've seen from South Africa at the
moment I I think they'll be too good and
then they'll Advance through to the
final and the All Blacks will beat them
there how good but yeah I I'll back
South Africa in this one it's going to
be really tight though like within seven
points 100% wow what are you going snake
it's interesting from suly I think
there's a lot of things in South
Africa's face for this game um I think
obviously the DuPont situation it looks
like he's going to play which is
fantastic because the the biggest games
need the biggest players in the world
for them to be the the showpiece
spectaculars that we all want to see
it's just it's going to be a hell of a
challenge for him like mentally after
that injury to can he be at his full
normal self playing the way that we've
seen him play for the last couple years
that that's the first thing I think
South Africa also coming off the bye so
Razz's had two weeks now to prepare for
this game
I think uh in a tournament with a short
turnaround like a World Cup the the
extra week of prep I mean Jimmy you've
coached like the extra seven days to
prepare for a matchup I think does
really benefit sides at this level um
but I think France France run a super
super aggressive and physical defensive
system and I think they can potentially
expose my concern with South Africa
which is this Obsession they have with
forward play and physicality and winning
the game line because if France get up
with 880,000 frenches behind them
singing the National Anthem four times
before the games kicked
off if France get up and win those
collisions for the first 20 minutes I
just unless South Africa do a full 18
180 on how they've been playing this
whole world cup I I don't know how
they're going to break this French team
down I just think France are a more
varied more balanced team I think
they've got more tools in the in the
Arsenal and I just think they get up at
home this week right I I am with you
snake I think this is France you you
said a lot of things favor South Africa
but I think the fact that France going
to be playing a World Cup quarterfinal
at home with potentially 80,000 French
fans behind them the noise the passion
that these guys have return off Dupont
the Stag is set for this guy he is the
greatest player we've seen for a very
long time and I cannot wait to see him
show that I don't think the cheek's
going to affect him he's not it's not
part of his game chucking his head into
Dark Places and trying to win Jackal no
one really touches him anyway he's that
skillful and that fast and just that
that smart that I I think he's going to
really show us how good he is on the big
stage and yeah I think the French are
going to do this one um and it's
probably one of the ones I'm most
confident about really like I I really
rate the way the French play um I I
think South Africa are going to just
rely on penalties I can't see them
giving the ball to too much air with the
way the French Wingers defend um they'll
sort of shut that down and make them go
into their kicks pretty early but um
it's going to be a matchup it's going to
be physical um there could be cards with
this sort of physicality so they're
obviously big part in the game if they
do happen but hopefully obviously the um
refs have been named tmos I haven't seen
any sign of the tmos which weirdly is
probably more important than the referee
these days I know it shouldn't be like
that we we've mentioned that we're not
fans of how much involvement the tmos
are having I don't think world rugby
have got that right um but it is the way
it is so guys have to adapt to these
tackles and when they are trying to be
this physical and come off the line and
smash these collisions they have to be
very careful with their body height and
make sure they're not connecting with
any shoulders cuz I see rassis come out
already say the French if they get a
little clip anywhere near their head
they're pulling the full soccer
Hollywood and making a real scene to get
the TMO to check and we know the
TMO the cameraman apparently are all
French so they'll be getting the replays
up there pretty quick there'll be a lot
against the South Africans in this game
um so yeah I think the French will win
it and set up um one hell of a
semi-final well potentially even more
hell of a final because I guess the
thing I see from this weekend is
whatever two teams or whatever four
teams win the quarterfinals we're going
have a lot more one-sided semi-finals
than quarterfinals so I see both the
winners of Pool A and B um whoever that
is whether it's France or South Africa
or Ireland New Zealand both going
through to the final relatively
convincingly and it could be as much as
a 4050 Point semifinal I believe I think
it's that one-sided anyone disagree
there no I 100% agree Jim I think it's
just a shame isn't it like no one wants
to see a 50o blowout in a World Cup
semi-final um these are brilliant
matchups this week but next week's going
to be a tough preview show isn't it
because I think we're all going to agree
and we're all going to say the same
things yeah it'll all be about picking
your fantasy triple Captain next week
who's going to get all the tries in
those 50o wins that is why fantasy rugby
makes this game great but any leaving
thoughts from you sirley nah just
hopefully the all black lads can put on
a clinic cuz yeah like I said before to
go out in a quarterfinal would be a real
shame but if the result doesn't go our
way I would urge all black fans to
remember that we're up against a great
Irish side so it just happens to be a
quarterfinal it's it's more the fact
that we'd be losing to Ireland so yeah
I'm back in the All Blacks of course but
just keep that in mind cuz we don't need
to pile on the lads if it doesn't go our
way 100% And remember that there's also
three great kiwi Lads in this Irish side
jamson Gibson Park water lad Legends so
so as James L two of the great episodes
of water lad along with Jacob Atkins um
there's some great episodes out there so
of course Bundy I as well he's yet to
come on but maybe after this Rugby World
Cup he would be a great shout but good
luck this weekend Lads enjoy the footy
it's going to be some Rugby World Cup
quarterfinal and um yeah up the a cheers
followers thanks for tuning into to the
episode since you've made it all the way
to the end I'm hoping that you've
enjoyed the episode and if you have
there's just a couple of things you can
do to help me out first is to subscribe
or to follow to whatever platform you're
listening to it on that roughly takes
one second secondly if you could give it
a five-star review that roughly takes
two seconds that helps out massively too
and thirdly you could write a wonderful
review about the podcast if you've got a
spare minute or two that also helps out
more than you know lastly I forgot about
this one but if you really want to help
out go and get yourself some wad merch
at water.com and help spread the love
appreciate it
what a what a what a what an absolute
GL what a what a what a what an
[Music]
absolute